good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight you wonder if looking
backward many years from right now
historians will notice the remarkable
coincidence in timing have you noticed
here it is
at exactly the moment when the emergency
powers they awarded to themselves to
fight kovid started to wane
our leaders began pushing for conflict
with russia and then on the basis of
that conflict they assumed historic war
powers
without even pausing the bidet
administration declared total economic
war on a sovereign country no american
had been killed the united states had
not been invaded or attacked and yet
with no meaningful public debate or
congressional authorization the byte
administration destroyed that country's
currency then removed it from the
international banking system that
impoverished its population
then the administration began seizing
the property of people affiliated with
that country without a trial or due
process of any kind without even
bothering to explain exactly what crime
they had committed
no american government had ever done
anything like that before if there was
one thing the u.s government long stood
for it was the rule of law
the integrity of the system was always
the most important thing but not anymore
that turned out to be an era and that
era is gone
because the target is russia very few
americans have noticed any of this they
support it virtually no one has paused
to ask him or herself where this might
be going how long until our leaders do
something similar to their domestic
enemies here in the united states how
long before they accuse you of collusion
or disloyalty or some other hard to
define crime declare you an enemy of the
state and then confiscate your bank
account
something very much like that just
happened in canada we don't imagine it
could happen here mostly we just don't
think about it what we think about is
ukraine
and that's the other thing that's
changed the tech monopolies now exert a
level of control over american public
opinion that has no precedent in all of
history eliminating section 230 or
whatever piddling reform congress is
talking about at the moment it all seems
like a joke at this point it's too late
the medieval church had less command
over a society's emotions then facebook
and google and twitter now do
for the past two years you have watched
these companies above all define who you
as an american must hate
depending upon their directive of the
day our citizens dutifully change their
social media avatars from blm signs to
mask up slogans to now ukrainian flags
each is a crisis and each new crisis is
carefully staged managed from silicon
valley at the direction of the white
house
how does the human brain compete with
this how does it understand it well it
doesn't
clarity and perspective become
impossible
in the hysteria even the recent past
just evaporates
the morning that russia invaded ukraine
you may have been talking about a lot of
different things covid or crime or the
southern border
not anymore
much relief for the white house all of
those topics have been forgotten maybe
forever
no population has ever been more
skillfully manipulated than our
population is being manipulated right
now
but even with the tech monopolies on the
case full time there are limits some
topics cannot be hidden and inflation is
one of them google can delete all the
search results it wants but you still
know what hamburger and gasoline cost
because you go to the store you know
exactly how bad inflation is and it's
bad in fact inflation is so high right
now that even affluent people are
worried about it and not worried in some
abstract sense like about the long-term
health of the country though that too
people who make 250 grand a year are
worried they will not be able to
continue living as they do now
you may or may not feel sorry for them
but let's put it in perspective imagine
if you made 50 grand a year or 30 grand
here as many americans do
you would be terrified in the face of
this inflation and maybe you are
so what's causing it what is the root of
the inflation
if you want to know the answer to that
question the fastest way to get it is to
check to see what politicians are
denying whatever they claim is not the
cause of inflation almost certainly is
the cause of inflation and with that in
mind here's joe biden telling you that
government spending has nothing to do
with it
we're on track right now
i'm on track to be the first president
of history to lower the deficit by over
one trillion dollars in one year
so i'm sick of this stuff
[Applause]
we have to talk about it because the
american people think the reason for
inflation is government spending more
money
simply not true
now you can say well that's just joe
biden joe biden's never had a real job
even before he became senile he was
reputed to be a dim bulb and he was
but don't kid yourself
in the clip you just saw joe biden knows
perfectly well he's lying it's simply
not true he squeaks really joe biden how
is it simply not true
notice he doesn't tell you how it's
simply not true because in fact it is
emphatically unequivocally true
inflation is a function of money supply
the more money you have in circulation
the less that money is worth even joe
biden understands that
the month after biden became president
the supply of u.s dollars in circulation
increased more than it ever had before
in a single month and then it kept going
higher month after month after month as
the administration and the congress kept
the money taps open and that's why we
have historic inflation now because they
printed too much money it's not
complicated but it's not the whole story
it did not start with joe biden to be
fair
in the months after the 2008 financial
crisis the federal reserve assumed
emergency powers to respond to the
financial collapse now if you're
noticing a theme here the people in
charge giving themselves emergency
powers in the face of a crisis they
created you may be onto something
but any case after 2008 the fed dropped
interest rates to near zero and then
began printing money this was supposed
to save our economy
and maybe it would have saved the
economy if it had ended at some point
but it did not end it went on to the
present day that's nearly 14 years
and in the process what was designed to
save our economy destroyed our economy
several times over the years wiser heads
at the fed talked about dropping the
emergency measures and reintroducing
reality into the american economy
reintroducing market forces remember
those but each time they contemplated
this wall street revolted in very public
ways
wage growth in the productive economy
had stalled but the market for private
jets was booming
so asset inflation became the basis of
wealth for many people at the top end
buy things then sell them for more make
nothing
now no society can continue like that
for very long because it's not
inherently productive it's a shell game
but ours did
for more than 14 years and in the
process this country became more
lopsided economically than it's ever
been fewer people owning more of
everything
the fed was fully aware of this they're
not stupid they knew they were causing
these trends and that most of these
trends were dangerous and bad for
america but the truth is nobody could
stop it
fed governors understood that markets
would tank if they tried to pull back
so it was really a classic ponzi it was
criminal mismanagement of our economy
but nobody could stop doing it for fear
the whole thing would collapse
and now we're at the end stage the fed
is out of tricks
the problem with inflation and some
economists want limited inflation at
certain periods some people in davos
have been calling for it for years but
the problem with inflation levels like
this is there is no simple way to pull
them back the fed cannot painlessly
massage its way out of seven dollar a
gallon gas prices
so when you reach a state as we are now
you really have only two options you can
pretend it's not happening
or you can blame someone else for it
and the white house is trying both
here's treasury secretary janet yellen
trying the first
we really protected most americans from
severe financial crisis consequences of
the pandemic so that
they're
by and large in good financial shape um
poised to spend enough to continue
propelling solid growth in the u.s
economy and we're seeing that in the
labor market
now you wonder as you stare into a
camera and say something like that if
you imagine if you can convince yourself
there's a single human being who
believes you things are great you should
be grateful for our wise stewardship of
your economy
keep in mind the woman you just heard
jenny ellen was the chair of the federal
reserve for four years
so not to be technical about it but if
anyone is culpable for the disaster
we're living through now it would be
janet yellen so she knows she's lying
and she's not even lying very
effectively because once again americans
understand
the state of the economy because they
live within it they pay for things
so if you're going to lie about its
cause you're going to have to do better
than just pretending it's not going on
you're going to have to blame somebody
else
and so the white house enlisted joe
biden's publicist to make a video
about vladimir putin watch this
you may have noticed this week that your
gas prices have gone up i want to talk
to you a little bit about why a lot of
it has to do with vladimir putin and
there's opportunities to produce more
from here but part of this is on the oil
companies right now there are 9 000
approved unused permits that oil and gas
companies could tap into now to ramp up
production that's why the president has
been so focused on investing in clean
energy technologies so that we can rely
on that and not president putin to set
the price of gas
i want to talk to you a little bit about
why that's happening what do you work at
npr now you don't know anything you are
a publicist
please stay in your lane
but she's telling us that actually oil
companies which we assumed were very
greedy and that was the problem with
them in fact don't want to make money
that's their real secret and that's why
they're not drilling for oil anymore
because
they just don't want the oil because
they're oil companies and they're
altruistic or something
she must have learned that in gender
studies class that oberlin now she's
telling the rest of us but really gen
saki said it's about vladimir putin
it's vladimir putin's fault you're
paying more for gas now the truth is
vladimir putin did invade ukraine that's
true
that's bad
but that's not why you can't afford to
fill your tank
it was the white house and we should say
the congress's reaction to the invasion
that is ruining our economy that's true
so among many other things the white
house just banned russian oil imports
for example oil prices immediately rose
that's what happens when you shake up a
market like that americans immediately
suffered we were told many people told
us it's worth it because this is a moral
victory against putin and some people
took solace in this
but you have to wonder how exactly is
this a moral victory against putin think
about it for a minute russia is a major
oil producer jensaki said that in her
interminable video a moment ago
that would mean that higher oil prices
help putin
they make putin and the saudis and the
venezuelans and iran much much richer
why because russia can still sell its
oil in global markets because the world
has not joined our boycott
what does this tell you
it tells you that the loser
in this policy is not vladimir putin
he's the winner
it's the united states and it's not just
oil
thanks to the body administration's
mismanagement commodities across the
board are up dramatically potash
fertilizers wheat huge nickel went up
250 percent in two days
who's going to pay for all this you are
this is the biggest tax increase of your
life and by the way it could very easily
get worse why
because oil is traded in u.s dollars
ever hear the term petro dollars
why would the rest of the world continue
to trade oil in u.s dollars a fact that
greatly benefits us
when there's uncertainty imposed by
political forces on oil markets there
would be a huge incentive to trade oil
in another currency maybe the chinese
currency maybe the euro maybe crypto who
knows but there will be new and
competing markets in which oil is traded
in something other than u.s dollars and
that's a massive loss for us here's the
bigger truth
our global financial systems benefit us
that may not be fair but it's true and
they're the basis of our wealth
so if you destroy them in an effort to
get putin who are you really destroying
you're destroying the united states and
that's exactly what they've done
when you attack and destabilize the
global financial systems to restate
you're attacking and destabilizing the
united states not putin
you can't see this right now because
there's so much hysteria being ginned up
by the media particularly on social
media
but when that hysteria lifts when the
cloud finally evaporates it will be
obvious that the byte administration's
response to the invasion of ukraine is
the single most damaging thing any
american president has ever done to this
country and to the world not to putin to
us and to a lot of small countries that
didn't deserve it
it's hard to see that now all you're
seeing are ukrainian flag emojis on
twitter but someday we will assess this
moment with clear heads and when we do
we will be horrified hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else